to this week's Android developer owner
welcome to this week's Android developer
office hours there's a glitch in the
matrix MIT went P I'm joined here today
by Matt gone Nick butcher and we're
based in the London office Google and
we're to take your Android development
questions should you have any so please
join us in the Hangout today come along
and ask any Android development
questions you may have you can ask them
in the moderator you can find that at
developers.google.com slash live or you
can ask them on the comment thread to
this particular hangout may we just hang
around for a second see if someone joins
us in the hall it's always more fun if
you have some live participants notice
we answered all the Android developers
are exhausted well let me see
unfortunately clock excellent I'm gonna
open up the thread for this hangout and
see if there's anyone asking to join a
couple of viewers on YouTube maybe we
should check the YouTube comments
this complaint would you say if you want
to ask questions and you don't want to
jump into the Hangout if you're shy then
feel free to as rich says either post on
the G+ thread where were you kind of
them where Android purposes is hanging
out you can post there or you can post
comments on the YouTube or you can
submit them to the moderator which you
can find if you go to
developers.google.com slash live we
should be the top show on there saying
live now and you can post a comment
right there we've got two people now
we've got Alex and now people coming do
you want to do any of the people who've
just joined when I say hello introduce
himself and ask a question
okay I'm Alex I did a few weeks ago the
ticketing system on the doctor I met
Richard so I haven't got any exes for so
good one how's it going thanks for
joining us today well I've actually
questions related to that so we had a
doctor around 30 devices linked into one
Google account and sporadic sign arts on
some of the devices is that a limit on
the number of active devices per account
almost certain straight out of his
microphone spread out via speakers make
his microphone yes there's almost
certainly a limit I've never come across
it myself but if you are trying to share
one set of credentials with a large
number of devices I can imagine there
would be some protection that kind of
behavior especially when you're looking
at pale applications for next year I'll
find something else probably works quite
well as if you have your own Google Apps
domain you can create them for free
anyway and you get 50 free email
accounts with that I've seen people use
that to set up devices before because
we're a bit more lenient on Google Apps
domain because you are administering the
email accounts not us whereas if you're
using at gmail.com addresses it's it's
us as Google that's administering those
accounts so there's there's stricter
guidelines on them actually on that
domain okay yes still going to apply
because that same limitation would apply
but you could more easily create a large
number of email addresses inside your
own domain attention than you would be
able to on our domain the real names
policy applies to people inside their
own domains I imagine it and I guess it
doesn't you know standing out homes with
ignitions it's your own administrators
yeah
anyway thank you travels in having I
guess because they was there mister how
to proceed with what directly into
application yes this was last question
but I said last week you should add it
into the moderator for this week so we
review it
I look very well did not even find there
anything useful so I think that or there
is no solution to get the Bluetooth
directly into the rock or we must find
something with the reflection or I use
it the Sun I used the some hood code
from Motorola
open-source they have some adopted the
application moved a lot but starting at
the 4.1 I cannot anymore open that the
doctor now is just a private cannot get
it anymore
start in the 4.1 yep so what was the
problem with opening up the socket and
getting the information through that I
guess he once used Bluetooth file
transfer protocol so that any other
application running device can send it
without having to be his application
running on the device yeah I know yeah I
don't know if the foreground activity
can override Bluetooth file handling or
not and I didn't check it out because it
wasn't on the moderator and I told you
forgot do is look in the same places
that your developers would look in right
I'm just going to look straight in the
Android developer documents and on Stack
Overflow and then repeat what I find to
yourself yeah there's quite a few
Android engineers that answer questions
directly on Stack Overflow though and
and members of our team as well so he
wants to be deluded of wesen there yeah
yeah absolutely
yeah Stack Overflow in case the answers
there already of course right
did you mean someone else already asked
that question basically you're good here
but what good accent yeah sorry we
totally forgot about that does anybody
else from the Hangout have any questions
Before we jump into the first one from
the moderator today I have a question
who said that did he say oh yeah yeah
Justin okay shoot
so my question is actually Bluetooth
related and it is it is the Google Music
app is somehow giving information over
like a VCR P 1.3 I think it is and so
users are able to see like artisan
albums on a car stereo
thanks I'd like to be able to do the
same thing and one or two other apps are
also doing it but I can't find any
documentation and I also can't find
anything on Stack Overflow it's like a
hidden secret right now yeah I was gonna
say just look at the source code for the
music app you can get source code to
Google music mm-hmm it should be under
the packages of the open-source project
I think you can get the source code for
the old music app but not like Google
music that streams music fair enough
noise possible yeah yo the old one is in
yes oh it's beautiful the old one yeah
when she says music is the old version
well before it went Google music music
hmm yeah so it's possible that those
guys are using
and it's possible that those guys aren't
using the high level Bluetooth api's
they mail while we're doing it even
using the NDK or something opening
Bluetooth connections and sending the
data across I'm not I don't know I
haven't seen any high level Bluetooth
api's for doing anything like that okay
so I should just post a stack overflow
yeah if no one has already written an
implementation which can do what you
want it may be quite tricky to write
that I guess if you ask it then someone
who might have more experience at a
different level Bluetooth or various
things and it may not be a case you get
the B on sir but people might be able to
guide you just give me better start
thinking about it looking about it other
examples that may be relevant yeah over
the last three weeks we've had quite a
lot of Bluetooth questions coming up now
so then you probably set up a Bluetooth
focus so promise is a little bit strong
commit
suggested okay suggested that it does
seem to be something that we the lack of
documentation on or something we should
have a show specifically dedicated to so
we'll look even a stronger suggestion
that getting that put together in the
near future I know that we're traveling
again quite a lot until Christmas so
it's gonna be tricky but it's gonna have
to go to the top of the list of things
to focus on is either more Bluetooth
documentation or or just more
information about it generally okay well
looking in the comment thread here on
the GPS placed as a couple questions
coming in and I guess we did we cover
off our normal disclaimer Android
chatting about how to develop Android
apps and we're not gonna be able to
answer questions such as when is Google
now coming to argentina unfortunately
we're not gonna be able to make those
kind of pronouncements and someone else
is asking when he's gonna get an update
to his Galaxy Nexus again I don't know I
know it's rolling out slowly just keep
on mashing that check for updates button
and see what happens and there is one
question here it wishes and Thomas asks
and
if we're gonna bring back a programmatic
way to switch flat mode on/off and
there's an interesting point actually
because then this is one of the changes
I think we've covered briefly yes last
week in fact we're with the changes for
an unreformed do introducing multi-users
we moved some of the settings into a
global settings Tunes which affect all
device rather than the user specific
system one of which was a setting for
flow and so I kind of I'm going to take
a bit issue with the question here which
is we bring back the programmatic
chromatic API 410 or flight mode and I
would actually argue that there never
was a programmatic API like you know
explicit API for turning on off the
flight mode people worked out how to
poke a value into a settings table and
do something else and it for it to take
effect that was never actually a
documented API I would say people kind
of working out how to do it isn't isn't
really the same thing I'd say when we
have an actual API like a connectivity
manager dot whatever and you know that's
a commitment for us to support and say
this is how you do such a thing so I
think that's why we kind of felt able to
move where it was and perhaps you know
some applications may no longer be able
to turn on flight mode but that's just
the way it is so yeah that's the kind of
a long answer saying that yeah there's
nothing we're not gonna bring it back
doing the kind of existed but and the
second part of this question asks is
there a way to ask for such improvements
and the answer is yes so if you go to is
it beaver Android comm which is where
you have details on how to file bugs on
the Android platform you can find a bug
with a type feature request and unlock a
feature request like it may sound like
you're shouting shouting into a black
hole but we do actually read every
single bug and feature request and we
might not have time to respond to all of
them and comment and have get into
discussions but we do certainly read
them all or the Android coroner identity
and product managers read them all and
fax them into next releases so yeah
there is definitely low key or low key
feature requests there or search if
there's an existing one and get people
to star it to show how how much people
want it absolutely and for applications
that were setting flight mode definitely
they should be setting users sending
users now directly to the settings
screen for that the network settings
screen I know that quite a lot
of the home screen widgets have already
done that update so um
pressing their widget now just goes
there instead the issue is of course for
those applications that said it'll
automatically yeah it's a bit tough for
them won't be a way of doing that yes
does that mean you can ask questions
about the developer play console hearing
you can you pass me if your microphone a
bit closer to your mouth yeah yeah I was
using another one anyway I would like to
know about this search and the position
criteria let me make an example I have
an application that the name is a
giuseppe okay giuseppe if i search in
the toolbar
I search Giuseppe I find the first page
with the other application that have
some some juice at the word inside the
description and in the second page I
found my application that have disobey
as name right so the criteria of the
research I think is all wrong or
something is not working well and
seconded the position how is it possible
that in in the same category there are
from the 1st to the 10th position there
are application that have very move
downloads very low review range but they
are in the first 10 position and my
application that have every day is good
I am regretting every day yeah what is
it and just to finish what is this
review now with a Google user say a
Google user we don't see it anymore the
name of the user till till until last
week
was able to find the name and to try to
understand what is the problem and to
reply to the user but now we really lost
the contact with the user sorry we are
going to not get any more any chance to
reply to these it's okay it's getting
better not worse so the first one
obviously we don't really comment on
search algorithms things like that but
the search algorithms are based on a
huge number of criteria that are there
to produce on maths the best results for
the users it may not be the best results
when you are searching for your own
personal application but though you know
it's the it's an iterated algorithm to
provide good results for users in search
okay and just like our Google search we
don't go into the exact details of which
you know factors are kind of contribute
to it I mean that's kind of our secret
sauce and also probably wrong because
it's changing every single day that
we're always tweaking this algorithm to
try and try and you know produce the
best possible search results so yeah
we're not gonna be able to that you'll
find things in there related to rate of
change as well as just fixed values the
same one we are ranking things the rate
of change of things inside the the
application is and of the ratings and
the number of installs and number of
uninstalls all those sort of things can
affect it and the rate of change of
those things can affect it as well but
as we say those things we're trying to
search through almost you know
three-quarters of a million applications
and surface the right one for your
search term and the search team are
constantly iterating that algorithm and
it like the web search as well some
people have benefits some people it
doesn't and they try and make a good
balance the same goes for the category
rankings as well and I think it's doing
the right job I mean just because he is
the exact match for the title doesn't
mean it's the best match for the search
term right I mean I could very easily
spam the search results just by putting
exact matches for no you know for car in
there and hopefully my app would go to
the top but actually it should be at the
very very bottom at 700,000 until it has
some traffic and some reviews and so I
know it's not it's not ideal for some
people it works very well for each other
you know the name of the allocation I
will not say here because
it's not correct but if you try to make
the research on the on the Google Play
market you will understand what I mean
you will see many many many applications
that have nothing to do with his name
and my application is adjusting the
second page and this for me is a very
strange it's like I'm looking for
someone that is named Richard on Google
and the he'd written to me Thomas that's
it you know I say that the issue with
that is almost the second word of the
application name here is sooo generic
very matching that second word the one
no it's do leads to common words but
move together only mine the two words
together if I put quotes around the two
words of the application they yeah but
could see support professional does it
is not for as you search is done by
individual words and you can't hope to
come near the top for the word Pro
unless you're changing yeah I've had
this one of my UPS where I had I did was
just make sure I had a good description
had a good title and everything make
sense if you're not I just left it and
eventually my acted just kind of filter
its way up to the top but I did notice
that the pay team they were adjusting it
and changing the algorithm and yeah I
don't think you can do to force it just
do what is right and just stick with
that and I'd say Pro is kind of a
generic term he's a bit bad yeah yeah
obviously we're not going to be able to
influence that algorithm we can let the
team know but and then regarding the
reviews yes previously anyone could type
any name they wanted into that box and
they were unverified so I could go in
and put just let people Shelly in as the
reviewer and say whatever I wanted about
your application so now we've put all
those just down to a Google user and all
reviews from now on a verified against
the Google+ account so from now on
you'll be able to see exactly who
reviewed it and it's a that we verified
against the Google account the real
identity that they logged in with so it
should be better for conversations for
going back
so you'll see these latest reviews it
and it's not to be very severely forget
the words will open we will see the main
you could already see yeah if you go to
some popular apps and sort the reviews
by newest first like so since this
change happen yeah your status you'll
see this result yes you'll see the real
people and their G+ profile picture is
pulled in either and so yes it's it's
forming a real conversation with a real
person so in the reviews section you
have to go and see see all and then it
brings up a page of all the reviews and
then there's a filter at the top where
you can say newest first and on there
you'll see I'm starting to come in with
real people's names verified accounts on
them verifying identities but yeah best
to go for an application that's getting
power through the reviews every day and
you'll see them all with with real names
their hand photographs next to them as
well your G+ profile photo will appear
next oh yes that's very good okay so
yeah it was just a to worry not it's
getting better it's getting better but
we had to do that yeah it's good you
know together do you think that in the
future that would be any chance to reply
use a review yeah I hope so yeah yeah I
mean it's in trial at the moment and
then still in its trial phase trying to
figure out how people best use that
feature and I make sure it's not used
for the wrong well on its own about easy
you know when you remove the anonymity
of just be able to put any name then
there's less kind of useless comments or
yeah hateful stuff they've all kind of a
bit more considered in their comments I
feel when it's your name and photo so
hope you increases the quality of the
discourse yeah correct correct and yes
following through and hoping the quality
of the applications because you can
really trust those reviews welcome to
everybody else who's just joined us in
the Hangout including Yossi good to see
you back on again there what have you
got in your lower third today you'll see
say something so I can see it say hello
something I think you're meted right now
hi guys oh here we go
over LLC okay sometimes you
for the rest of my life also okay does
anyone in the Hangout and one else in
the Hangout have a question yeah
guys I've got one Patrick I have a
question on the Android emulator on the
Mac ever since updating the SDK if you
close the Android emulator on a
secondary monitor
you can't restart it it'll crash every
time and you have to edit the emulator
user ini to change the window position
so it's back on the primary monitor
thank you very much it's really kind of
painful for mine my workflow because I
have three screens and I typically have
the emulator off a primary monitor the
good news about this is the tools team
is super reactive and if you go to tools
to Android comm you can file a bug there
and they will read it the same day or
probably placed into a GT directories
quickest way okay yeah if you search a
Google group called ADT - dev yeah
post it in there and I'm sure they'll
see it yeah post any information you
have on it there and they'll get it
sorted out as soon as possible I do run
a similar system here I haven't tested
that use case so I'll test it out myself
okay thanks I'll give a try
thanks very much though anything
happening in the comments thread there's
one question in the comments from Alex
who asked if there are any miracast
dongle is available yet very recently
we're kind of getting everyone super
excited I'm really excited to try I
haven't even tried one of these dongle
yet and yeah there was one on a melon
coming due date there was one on Amazon
us that said that it supports both the
Intel and miracast standard okay but
basically so files on an abd using the
external storage directory and then on
that calling list files and he's saying
on an ABT that will return no whereas on
the device it returns as documented and
he is doing a check to see whether the
media is actually mounted as well is it
there's no files on the SD card oh yeah
this is I'm wondering if it's not
actually mounted or yeah it could just
be empty I mean it's a one way would be
to in DDMS you can actually explore the
SD card right the emulator or checking
to see if are actually files or just
create a Vardon and see what it lists or
contacts
hmm and then there's another one from
Tim Rose question about HTTP client
versus HTTP URL connection node blog
entry from 2011 states that HTTP URL
connection should be preferred above
Android 2.3 just had a discussion in
hashtag Android flash dev or freenode
HTTP URL connection seems from Android
400 to have several bugs - that's the
current recommendation about those - no
what's the current recommendation about
those two HTTP clients it offers
features HTTP URL nation doesn't et
customizing methods acceptable to use or
should it be avoided so I guess it's
yeah which one yeah the general advice
is from two point three onwards so it's
from Gingerbread onwards to use a URL
connection sets the one which is
receiving active developments and yes
okay yes so the current advice is that
still the correct advice that and all
the work is going on URL connection so
things like response caches and so on
again edit your connection not actively
worked on in and HTTP client but then
again HTTP client is a very very rich
and well tested library you know from
Apache so it does offer a plethora of
kind of options which I guess haven't
quite made it into URL connection yet so
if there's something super specific that
your connection doesn't offer yet I
consider a completely valid to use and
and httpclient so yeah I would say for
above gingerbread use URL connection
where possible unless you kind of care
for this corner case that isn't covered
yet anything right no I completely agree
I think I've probably used both of them
and it's yeah it's just what I needed to
do yeah yeah often uh David Chandler is
a web and web view expert from the
Android developer relations team so if
you look for David Chandler on Google+
he may be able to provide more insights
into any specifics as well and he also
created a a HTTP library just any wish
and sits above the two of them and will
do the right thing you know on above
nine ill use your connection and below
use client and has an abstraction layer
on top of the two to take a look for
that as well which is feverishly
googling for it to post a link up in
there in the area as a reply so thanks
to the question google code at basic -
HTTP - client and you can find it on his
blog at turbo manage so it's basic -
HTTP - client say link in its response
google code calm I will he only did this
on the 6th of December so since I put it
that's the 12th of July June I would
like to see you got it smashed can you
hear me now yes hey you see ya
my question is about loaders since API
11 basically loaders were were added to
simplify the use and not use
Dasom tasks or whatever and use loaders
to fetch all the data and then the lower
level will handle all the configuration
changes for us but basically if I have
only one entry point for data like say
I'll do a and I am client okay okay tell
you what another thing I'll do a phone
dialer app okay but all the contacts are
on on the server so basically on the
first login I'll fetch all the data at
once and then I'll just store that on
the device or in database or in memory
and basically do all the manipulations
on it so what's the problem
how loaders can help me or save me time
because I still need to use adapters for
the ListView or basically switch all the
data from cursor adapters to the switch
to the ListView and loaders is just
another way to fetch the data right or
is it more than meets the eye
no that's exactly right it's an
alternative to distinct worry on the
content resolver but it's a bit smarter
so basically I don't have an an
obligation to use loaders if I can
handle all the configuration changes
myself in an obligation it's just
convenience is there to help make it
easier for you yeah but I mean in
performance wise is it better than using
our own check for configuration changes
and because basically all I do is fetch
the data first time upon login to see if
the contact list is changed and then
basically do all the manipulations
myself
and switch from our adapter to another
list viewer so on and so all the data is
always on on the list view or an adapter
so today you'll see it's gonna be a
better performance the answer's yes I
didn't know because the the joy of load
is is it takes care of a lot of work for
you right so it just like the content
observer for you for example so for me
that's one of the joys that you can
decouple your kind of say you're doing a
acquiring a rest service you can just
fire it off to an intent service and
have the intent service retrieve
information and put it into the content
provider and you don't have to worry
about then try to touch the UI because
because the loaders implemented a
Content observer for you it'll just see
the change to the on the content URI and
re query and update your URI for your UI
for you so you don't have to then you
know get into the messy logic of result
receivers and so on trying to ping back
from your intent service back to your
activity yes the kind of the joy of it
is it kind of handles a lot of that for
you and like you say handles and
configuration changes gracefully for you
as well so if you don't need any of that
and then don't use it I mean you know I
mean we most likely every app that uses
fetching from the internet and showing
list views and so on needs it but on
different levels because I can do all
the configuration changes and live
myself and basically if I use an area
adapter or a cursor adapter to hold the
data and as long as a persistent data as
long as the application is on the
foreground then I don't see why Lourdes
is better that's what I mean that's what
I wanted to verify with you guys yeah
okay thanks I guess one-one of argument
might be though that if he if if it
changes in the future that you might
want to watch for two content changes or
things like that then you know you were
then going to have to change all your
code and write all that stuff for you
whereas loaders are pretty easy to
implement if you just do it from the
start
but then you know if your requirements
change on you then you kind of have that
flexibility to react to it but I guess
you know your requirements better thanks
guys
okay hey Canton how you getting on there
oh you're single there's something wrong
with this isn't oh I'm sorry can you
hear me okay or is it just completely
screwed everyone up yeah okay yeah that
thing yesterday um special reto about it
as well in he's you wanted to know it's
the same problem you'd report to him
already
oh yeah and I got to the bottom of it
it's basically single shot used to give
you about four or five shots and now it
gives you a single shot which is
probably what it should have done in the
first place but it totally messed up
what I was doing with it so are you yeah
exactly because it really used to return
like about four progressively more
detailed versions so I just waited until
I didn't get one for ten seconds and
then use that but ignored the first one
cuz and now you only get the first one I
don't think the first one actually had
the payload in it before little
buoys location what like Groupon yeah
yeah I know that's all right I've
updated it and it's been pushed out so
hopefully hopefully people see it change
okay do we have any other questions from
the Hangout if not we'll head into the
moderator er I have a question hi there
hello can you hear me yeah we can only
find a timer
okay this is my first time on the
handout and the question I have is that
I'm pretty new to android developments
and I noticed that I had to learn Java
first you know that's with develop
programs and
hundred applications yeah and I was one
and we said just so we can be good to go
I'd stumbled on a scripting layer for
Android using Python and I have a very
good background with Python and I was
wondering wouldn't be what we call easy
Android developers can also look into
the area of integrating Python into
their SDK or having a development
platform for or Python or developing
apps that are the question I have yeah I
mean we've definitely have internal
conversations about these things before
I guess one of the limitations is the
size of the tools team we're focused
very much on progressing the platform
progressing the API is progressing all
that and if we were supporting two sets
of api's with two different languages it
would just slow everything down require
a lot more testing and we are very much
focused on the single language at the
moment because the issue using a
scripting language on top of Android is
you're not gonna get all the benefits of
the the responsive layout tools that we
have the the resources folder the values
all the things that are built into the
core platform to be to enable you to
write applications that work seamlessly
across the device ranges that we have
yeah so to put that all across to
another language via a massive
undertaking I think but certainly there
are people who where the platform's
moving so fast as well right like you
know a six-month leash release schedule
if not you know if you stop releases in
between like two one then you know it's
pretty hard to keep up with that let
alone yeah then I can totally see the
appeal of it and I don't know why a lot
of people are doing scripting layers on
Android and things like the mono library
for.net developers
yeah they there's definitely people who
would like to code in other languages
but certainly for me freelancing I guess
because today Michael seems to have a
lot of libraries too so handles so many
tasks and it would also be cool to have
its have the developers also concentrate
in that direction as well the Android
community also provides a vast array of
libraries for doing almost anything you
want to do an Android as well people
seem almost entitled to not write code
on Android these days they can't find a
library to do it the head of it
I had to write some code myself there's
so many Android specific libraries from
the community it's one of the most
excellent things about Android
I appreciate ya cheers thanks for coming
in though and if you have any other
questions feel free to send them our way
okay let's take one out of the the
moderator then because we store quite a
few to get through we've done already in
your life okay which ones have you done
them how'd you manage few recycling okay
then so someone whose name I can't
pronounce in Columbia says how do you
manage view recycling when you have a
different layout for each of you on the
list view in the list you okay
I've tried using get item view type and
then create a hold of class for each
case but it does not seem to work key
protocol specialist I think that's
actually not a bad solution hey you are
being asked in get item for a specific
view to be returned and you're given a
view that's now available if they don't
match you're just gonna have to scrap
the one that's not available let's come
back in so you have number of items and
then yeah that would try and recycle the
view that is the same type so it does
try to do a lot of these things for you
to when you're recycling okay the right
view holder to then yeah I don't know
buddy means why manage to be recycling
the note I know there is a limitation
there we'd you know we don't try and
hold on to an easy one of each type in
the recycle bin so that there's already
a constructed was view I guess if you
like to it so to convert for you that's
all what I think you there is so we
don't actually try and like hold one of
each type but yeah if there's 138 and
yes and if you do have any large list of
items with many different view types in
or a repeating set of view types
specifically and you don't have to keep
inflating them and you're getting handed
them backing in the wrong order there
should be a way of cashing those convert
views that come back in for somehow or
you could simplify it so you don't use
different item types but issues view
stubs within the item types it's all the
same time so you're always gonna get
hand
something we might have to inflate
personality didn't manage your auntie
recycling yourself you can keep your own
array of all the different views that
are going to be used and use the right
layouts as you need them
that are pre inflated yep and also I
should say Andrew Kelly zones are given
a pretty good answer in the moderator as
well so check that out yeah Andrew Kelly
thanks for that the one-man moderator
machine yeah but you should definitely
find a way of doing it without having to
re-inflate views that have already been
inflated oh that's quite expensive and
it's going to start freaking with your
heap free with the heap okay yep next
okay so DDR Box Minh in Austin Texas
asks it says that Android 4.2 and V 11
of the support library added the ability
to nest fragments within other fragments
indeed and but it seems that on activity
result is broken for these child
fragments is this a known bug or is this
by design I haven't tried on activity
result in this the fragments we were
just talking about this a bunch of time
so you're trying to set result from
within a nested fragment and you're
saying you don't con say I need some
more information of a CI so if enlisted
fragment is starting an activity for
result is it by design that you should
have to pass that back to the parent
fragment before you start that activity
chemist fragment startactivityforresult
and where does the activity result come
back into I mean if you guys don't start
an activity for result from a fragment
and then the results will return to the
fragment does it get returned to okay
yeah-oh from the fragment activity at
least yeah for Nativity not the Prem
yeah so it's coming here to it you know
presumably you could sort of do a bit of
a weird move backwards but then you'd
have to be aware it's a good point
can you start activity for result for
ensign friend Lucy what I was thinking
cuz I thought you know you coul start
from within the track going a bit then
you have to catch it so maybe that's it
yeah there are we going back to the
parent
friendly no - you need to make sure that
your routine down the right way so yeah
I guess it's a bit confusing exactly
what you're trying to do can you post a
follow-up comment with a link to a Stack
Overflow or somewhere where we can see
some code test case where it's failing
and we can take a look at that loops my
request showing you now I need to tell
off keep tapping noises on this thing -
no that shouldn't be true if I hold down
this bone here keep what settings I
think more reaches out let's crack on
so warlock in prague asks if I have five
fragments in the back stack eg ABCDE and
we're ears on top and all of them are
instances are the same and activity
class is there an easy way to navigate
straight from e which is on top direct
feedback to see I'm not using fragments
of wreckage or anything like that so I
guess we've seen jump backwards he means
he wants to pop off like the top - and
go back to back to the c1 there so you
can't use the activity flags because
it's gonna because they're all the same
activity class so it's interesting to
know why you want to do that because it
sounds like if you're trying to go
straight from E to C that if it's a drug
navigation that you know it should be a
new one on the top of the stack and if
you are just trying to get back to where
you are as in are you always trying to
skip to eat that is that the case will
you always skip that will you never ever
want to come back to that defragment I
then there is an activity flag that you
can start to say don't include this in
the back stack right yeah yeah there's a
lot of this kind of a number of ways
that you can kind of approach this the
right one I guess we did depend peony on
what you're trying to do but yeah my
default instinct would be to kind of
pick the right flag or if worse comes to
us if dear you literally don't with him
once you've kind of gone past it then at
that point finishing it mm-hmm so yeah
the check flags as well as trying yeah
come back to us with a bit more detail
passing and giving more of a solid
answer hmm
we've got any more in moderator we've
got and you'll see you also helpfully
says use Navi tails as well so nav utils
is in the class in the support library
which will help you to synthesize back
stacks and so on that helps you set like
where to navigate to up and right yeah
but basically a course or edit the task
at the stack trace an ADD task or create
already at moderate ones I believe one
only the entire nested fragments and
closing an emulator for my second screen
the earlier last question is just to
here New Zealand says GPS up guide
question my question my question was we
can I add more related question to the
loaders yeah sure
say you'll have a list of thousand
people in your country and basically you
have a status for each for each member
in the contact list and if one of the
users change the display name or status
or something then basically the loader
will fetch all the data again and that's
one be con cons versus versus the
adapter that we can only change the
specific data that was changed right
exactly yeah it will monitoring the
whole net and content URI all right so
if anything in that content URI changes
is gonna require it hoping so that's a
big performance issue
okay just a very frame sure so what was
that we'll pull out all of the data
again
yep no we query queries Oh women if
we're pulling out would just be
returning a different cursor and then if
you doing into an adapter it just put
updates those for use with it not the
teaser on screen yeah yeah but yeah I'll
have to create a whole database thing
yeah how is the G+ thread going on yeah
I'm just taking another class one of us
are free and a web us how does it handle
multiple devices if I use the same app
in different devices that developers do
anything special to handle it can it be
used as a sync mechanism between
different devices no personally no I
would yeah try and use something like
Google Drive we did a code lock on it
recently and it's available through our
G+ streams quite like the idea of giving
users control over their own data anyway
so if you're using Google Drive to sync
your data they can see it they know that
it's not on your servers that they've
got hold of it and and it will
definitely work across all devices is it
confirmed as well because when you
request sync as well it doesn't happen
synchros it kind of goes onto a task
queue happens at some point which we
don't make many guarantees about so it's
quite hard to guarantee that the new
state has been synced up and then also
when you request restore from backup
manager that was kind of broken on a few
versions of Android so it's not the most
reliable thing - it seems quite reliable
if you're on the same device here but
across devices they're definitely issues
we have takers backup manager the actual
use cases working user cases of it are
quite limited it works really really
well don't get me wrong I think everyone
should use backup manager it works
really really well for the case of like
for a new device and I'm signing in
please get all my app to how it should
be you should be definitely be
definitely backing up things like share
preferences or you know any
configuration the users done to your
application certainly definitely use
backup magic but can be used to make a
syncline
between apps I know that's not really
already as built before it doesn't
really work that way unfortunately yeah
I agree rich like yeah given the users
control of their own data for syncing
the data between devices is somewhat
like Drive and that's we're just
specifically talking about using backup
manager to backup data to the play
servers because backup managers actually
a whole plug-in framework where you can
choose to backup to sd card or your own
services you could write a Google Drive
backup manager or a Dropbox backup
manager plug-in if you wanted and do it
somewhere else so the limitations on the
Google Play plugin for it that really
it's just designed so that has people
reinstall the application at the Play
Store the data will then get restored
with it yeah yeah you can choose just so
Eric says I have an image view that is
rotated using set rotation and it shows
a card frame photo by setting a
background drawable and a photo using
set image durable however only the
outside of the background is anti
aliased how can I get the front orb or
the photo to be drawn anti aliased
as well you know it isn't this - so how
would you answer yes there - photo of an
image you because I'm imagining the
background is going to be dealt with by
the actual view itself whereas the image
is going to be drawn on top and actually
managed by the image view only the
outside is antialiased horrible to be
antialiased as well a little bit me
things that should be an option to do
that whether you could wrap the so if
it's a resource from the system could
you not try nothing with there's an anti
alias option when you wrap it in an XML
drawable no not that I know of no I'm
also interested about what the scale
type might be on it as well because if
the drawables I'm guessing the dribble
is much bigger than these actually
displaying it on screen in which case
you know that's why he's worried about
the MTA's and stuff because it has been
resized down or something can you set
that with a scale type I can you provide
your own matrix to scale it or can you
pre scale the bitmap before setting it
and so you don't have to set a scale
type this is what I'm thinking yes in
amounts to pre scale the bitmap yourself
you probably would have the the right
flags and map manager when you scale it
to do the anti-aliasing and then just
set the scale bitmap if you're leaving
UPS the image view to fit then you end
up killing provided what it thinks is
the best option well yeah it's just not
gonna do it yeah so that's something I'd
look into yes only try scaling the image
yourself before and they're saying you
know the pre scaled image on the
chemistry so I can think of right now
any restrictions anyone done is in the
hangar yes we have Guiseppe here
pointing at yourself thank you I'm using
the Google Cloud messaging such as free
and starting two weeks I noted that
there are about 50 percent of the users
that they register to get the Google ID
that fails they don't get the Google ID
is there any issue on the server side or
sorry no I never had a failure rate
anyone hear that before
no no issue at the moment so about 50
bucks say 1,000 years you users I'm
getting 500 that don't get the response
back from the from the service you're
just getting no response at all from GCM
yes they fell response see no register
it did you use to use cloud-to-device
messaging and then upgrade to GCM or yes
to the laceration yes are you still
supporting c2dm as well as GCM yes and
you're definitely sending the right
messages to the right clients yeah
because I think everything's right
because I get to the ALF of the users we
did the right ID so if I want something
this don't master it'll nothing no I'm
just understand that you've still got
some of your old user base I'm concerned
some of your old user base it'll has
clients that's using the old c2dm format
and they'll make the requests to your
servers using c2dm but if you go to our
GCM servers they will never get the
notification you have to send that
request through the c2dm servers to get
to those if you still have clients that
are using c2dm yeah this is a student
working now you sure yeah sure sure but
this kind of failure rate it feels like
there's something serious I just I just
get in the the CCA GCM intent service I
get back to the on on a register
vertical but for the for the older users
that are still using c2dm
no there is no universe that is using
the old API
are you sure sure sure sure sure sure
okay if you want that can later the
code somewhere yeah yeah it's possible
because there were some people who had
that issue that assumed after that
upgraded to GCM they only had to support
GCM but actually during the migration
period they definitely still need to
support c2dm and GCM no no no okay just
using the last duration and ye know that
you see she you never actually read the
universal okay in which case there's
definitely something wrong in the
pipeline we don't have any open issues
that I know about with you GCM and all
the messages are getting delivered that
I know about and 50 percents are pretty
huge failure right Kent in your big TVs
right yeah right and yeah you have I
mean sometimes get some delays getting
responses from it that they eventually
do will come through
it doesn't just fail in its spell again
it doesn't just fail on the registration
I do get sometimes in my logs saying GC
I'm not registered that it's already
registered anyways so I'm not paying too
much attention to at that point and I'm
not getting fair I'm not getting any
further failures I'm not I'm not
explaining that very well I'm like at
the moment every time the app starts it
goes through the register the GC and
registration process which I'm not sure
that it should do that I need to check
and let's check into that and they're
off the time it will come back saying GC
I'm not registered but it is registered
from the last time it run so it's
checked unknown issues you have no okay
no issues regarding GCM at the moment
so it sounds more likely to be something
on your side Giuseppe yeah yeah yeah
double check and as you think I only
shaved the code somewhere yeah if you
get any debug through from the thing
that's failing we might be able to help
you out just mail it through and we'll
see if we can help you out if you can't
resolve it
thank you very much okay you find us in
the usual places
how it over time what happened to the
time to 59 years indeed it's one minute
till close there's anything anyone or
anything you know it might not be a
person have anything urgent to say
someone just joined us in the last
closing seconds on the hangout oh yeah
it's Paul here one quick question I'm
just wondering I know about the
orientation in landscape and portrait it
was quite a big thing before just
wondering if do you think everyone is
still doing that today or do you think
it people are going for more fixed
orientations these days both support
landscape and portrait I get really
frustrated depending on depending on the
screen really if you can do it in all
cases then doing in all cases will be
best
I mean it's deviator best thing by
default every option support both okay
unless you oh good reason not to
okay thank you yeah it's buses kind of
the beauty of Android you don't know
what the next light hit device is gonna
be and if someone decides to do
it's gonna be really painful if you
don't support both landscaping they kind
of prefer it that way we've been kind of
talking about an old-school Qi one
coming back to life yeah and a lot of
people use their Nexus 7's in portrait
because of the particular case I have
online I usually use it in landscape
because it just happens to sit that way
on my desk so apps that don't support
ons get good annoying and you're always
going to have that section of your user
base that are on the key devices would
slide out keyboards and then they also
feel excluded if they don't have a
landscape support as well yeah I would
wherever possible always designed for
uncodable just well unquestioned on that
how many people have physical keyboards
or slide a keyboard you know or what
kind of percentage I don't have any
statistics on that okay
no all the devices that have to buy that
keyboards but now you look at adding
some analytics to your applications okay
cheers guys thank you all so yeah people
do use external keyboards Bluetooth
keyboards and other things he's just
gonna say like I've got two clients now
and they've posted they both insist they
just want portrait they don't care about
landscape I know Google TV guy on the
left there sort of is obviously would
love some landscape just be doing that
yeah and how do you convince clients and
it's worth spend your money on doing
both I'll just take it to you one in and
wait and wait for them to slide the
keyboard out and try and time that email
address in like this is what they hate
they use yeah just tell them default
well one of the organist I'd say is like
if you mean to or not you're already
shipping an app which runs on you know
landscape - you thought phones it runs
on landscape default or tablets runs on
loans quite escape you G TV's
not refreshing touch you know so they're
already shipping an app that does this
they're just shipping a really really
poor user experience so either you go to
loads of effort to kind of lock it down
and stop it from doing what it really
wants to do you think it how they want
to use the app or you have happier users
I said to them like
and if they're putting it wait a minute
it's quite nice and easy to sort of wait
lock it to one orientation it's a lot
less code as well
the is there anything that is there any
sort of like public thing that we can
say statistically this is like a class
of devices you're excluding if you lock
it to these orientations because I mean
you're kind of preaching to that convert
it here but we've got to convert our
clients that are the ones with the
wallet yeah I don't know any hard
numbers the only one I can really think
of is and the tab activation is now so
public number is we're activating 70,000
Android tablets every day so you know
they're already gonna not have a great
user experience and it with the app most
tablets are kind of pre landscape
friendly I don't have stacks of ways for
how many what class of devices I'll
strip convincing them make sure they do
a landscape version a tablet layout as
well I know they're often not easy
things to convince a client especially
if they've just finished their iOS app
oh no I mean I find I find like in the
the Nexus 7 plus size device actually
obscure phone apps looking right on that
it's more like a tablet device I find
like say you have to make it cool like
only hours don't work very well in
generally like it's okay with that we're
gonna have to finish for today before we
get actually physically kicked out of
this room thank you all for joining us
again some great questions from the
Android developer community
Giuseppe will try and look into that
question whatever it was by next week
please that into next week's moderator
and I'll take a look guys thank you all
very much